dad i finish it i am 25 female i have a
ninth month old and a fiance and a
full-time job two months ago my mom
moved in with me after having a stroke
i'm trying to be understanding about her
recovery but she doesn't try as hard as
she should and she manipulates me by
saying she's such a burden and we have
arguments over her insinuating that
somebody is stealing her meds my fiance
and i hardly even take anything for
headaches i don't know why i let her
move in with me considering she sat in
her bed for my whole childhood and
didn't take care of me she can do more
than she lets on this is leading me
towards hating her what should i do love
from kansas sounds like you've always
hated her bro
no that's a tough one man take your
mom's put this in the situation what
would you do she just had he called it
the stroke
not a stroke or after me having a stroke
okay yeah i think it's not what you
demand from life it's what life demands
from you so i would just hate your mom
but keep taking care of her you know
talk [ __ ] on her constantly and just
right into every podcast and say what a
[ __ ] crazy [ __ ] she is but still
feed her and scratch her back and [ __ ]
like that
interesting very asian of you very easy
dad
man
how do i add to that i mean i think uh
what would you do get her to take an ice
bath
dude yeah i mean i would
i would lead by example i'd show her
some b-hole sonning i'd hop in the ice
bath and be like mom follow suit
this is gonna boost your fault this will
de-stroke you it's gonna boost your
dopamine your norepinephrine yeah and uh
who knows it's gonna get the circulation
in your brain just firing so maybe
really good thanks yeah yeah i like it
you're offering solutions for her yeah
that's good i'd get her power lifting
like i like doing crossfit just put a
barbell in her hand she had a screen
typically when they have a stroke one
side's weaker than the other right
you know what you guys even know what a
stroke is bilateral oh yeah okay what is
it well there's two stroke and four
stroke on a dirt bike and the two stroke
has
[Laughter]
right that's exactly what what are the
two different types of strokes i don't
know the two butterfly and freestyle
there's the backstroke very good very
good breaststroke yeah
well there's like a there's the heart
one and then the dome one yeah
that is it's either there's julian
casablancas
another cool drummer who dates yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah all right yeah
so are we done with that improv game or
the stroke improv game wait what did he
say about her meds that's what i was
gonna say she's claiming that people are
stealing her meds so i would try to
clear her
paranoia
look mom
i got you this cabinet right
it's got a little you know i mean either
a code or a key that you have to open
you you're the only one that has this
key right just to get that because that
would drive me crazy right right if
she's constantly stop scaring my [ __ ]
man right that would you also have to
consider that she just had a real brain
injury and that can really cause like
differences and like changes in like
personality and things like that so if
she's experiencing some type of like
psychological stuff first i would have
her see somebody
that is dealing with either a paranoia
or
a lot of people that won't have the
money just no your insurance would pay
for that all right
i mean hopefully if that if you have
enough money to do that i would just
find her a different place can you get
is there a home that you could go to
this is difficult
it's a hard one yeah but i think i
really like what jt said about it's like
you can hate her just take care of her
yeah you don't have to like oh you
switched switch the mats jesus yeah
doctor you're cavorkian not kill
just chill her out chill meds the chill
stuff yeah the chill stuff like morphine
oh that's going to put her down down
down down maybe either way crush ups
matter i'll have her snort it
yeah yeah bang out some spreadsheets
yeah
right but something different
yeah mix it up yeah play chemist tweak
it around
yeah yeah it's fun to play the cranky
guy too like i messed up my taxes a
couple years ago yeah that was like my
first adult moment where i was like dude
like i was able to relate to people i'd
be like dude taxes right
so you could be like dude i can't
believe my [ __ ] mom and they're like
dude yeah you know this yeah there's
social currency in it like if you go out
and you're like uh i'm sad because i
have to take care of my sick mom
everyone will hear that and they'll
gather around appreciate you more for it
yeah right but so that'll make that will
soothe you is that what you're saying
yeah you get something out of it social
currency right maybe sympathy you'll get
sympathy likes yeah and people respect
you they're just a good person who takes
care of their mom but you still have to
go home and he'd be to live with that
[ __ ] yeah but no one knows you she
can't tell anyone you're cursing at her
and calling her names and stuff yeah i
think the problem
i think the problem is not necessarily
your mom
but your partner
like if my mom was here my like remember
when my dad had a stroke yeah
and
he if he moved in here right i would be
more paranoid about how you felt about
it because i know that i'd be frustrated
like my my dad's accusing us of stealing
meds he we're constantly you know i mean
i feel like i would deal with it much
better than you for some reason
yeah but i would still feel bad that you
had to [ __ ] go through it no because
i was raised in a household where you
take care of your elderly you don't you
don't put them in homes if they're a
burden they're a burden that's just
that's just your lot in life you have to
take care of your parents and
grandparents to the very end to the
bitter end that's like the same that's
just what i learned oh i know
can i say this
that's why i'm trying to make as much
money now as possible and i'll save it
until the end can you just hire people
right i like that do you like that
mm-hmm i think back then they'll have
maybe in the future they'll have an app
yeah i mean
like uh
they probably hire a nurse yeah and
they'll have reviews and stuff like
right right and go i wanna you know
do you wanna do to a gal
come on bro dude come on my mom was
the most sought after hospice nurses
so she was an end-of-life
nurse and she looked after a lot of like
celebrities like
transitioning
into
the next